the way you think about these things is
guys what's gonna what decision is gonna
put me in the best place 10 years from
now because good financial decisions
always hurt on the short-term and give
you the proper result in the long term
bad financial decisions always feel good
in the short term like when you buy that
car you can't afford or go on that
vacation you can't afford or do that
whatever you can't afford it always
feels good because it's an exciting
moment to get out whatever right
I always feel good on the short term but
the long term is disastrous and so one
of the things we found as we've surveyed
wealthy people is we have found that
they have a long-term planning window
they don't say thank God it's Friday oh
god it's Monday they don't live for the
weekend you know however that song goes
I can't sing but obviously but I mean so
I mean you don't live for the weekend if
you do your child that's something
people do in high school you know so are
you still uncle Rico I mean really are
you still living like you're in high
school you know no you can't you think
start thinking okay when I make this
decision how does it affect me 10 years
from now feels good right now but does
it affect me 10 years from now and so
like I had a friend the other day he did
a deal and he got a really big check his
check was over a million dollars nice
deal huh and he was fretting over buying
himself a watch he's a watch guy and he
bought a watch for seventeen thousand
dollars now that's a bad gum watch he's
fretting about that he said that what do
you think it was okay you think okay I'm
sorry okay by seventeen thousand our
watch dude you just cashed a check for
over a million dollars you could buy six
of those watches and drop them off the
bridge one at a time over the next six
minutes into the water they would not
affect your life
that's how you know it's an okay
decision you know how can I afford that
motorcycle if you could you know drive
it off a bridge and it wouldn't affect
your life if you just throw it away it
just blew it up just for the fun of it
would it affect your life then it's a
non-issue when it's a small percentage
of your world and that's where you want
to get to with cars and toys and
vacations where when you do them even
even with your generosity where when you
do it it doesn't affect your life yeah
that's good stuff this is the Dave
Ramsey show